there's so much to explore here I mean
if we wanted to we could just go to math
and be like I want to multiply this by
some special number such as I don't know
the movement speed for example and then
I want to put that into the playback
speed so if I now hit play and then I
move and the animation speed actually
plays a lot slower as well because it's
dependent on
movement welcome to another Hazel Dev
vog it's just as in development as the
engine itself all right what do I do
this
week the first thing I want to mention
is how I mean quite honestly blown away
I was by the support on the I'm
struggling video that I made I think
that because of the fact that my life
has been a little bit stressful over the
last 6 months I was on a little bit of
an autopilot just making videos like
spitting out content working on Hazel
whenever I really could which wasn't
often and I kind of forgot about all of
you I forgot about the fact that I have
this community of people who like I
don't know like me is that weird to say
it seems weird to say this amazing
community of people who support me who
like my videos and support the Hazel
project I think it's a little cliche to
say but it's honestly true that when you
make videos online or just any social
media really you kind of forget the
people behind the numbers you just see
the numbers and it's like okay cool
check like this satisfied the business
goals I can put food on the table and I
guess because of the AFF mentioned
autopilot state that I was in I was kind
of losing that that connection so I just
want to say thank you it was really nice
reading all of your comments and I was a
little bit surprised at how mature a lot
of those comments were like these were
not comments written by 15-year-olds
there were a fair few comments written
by people like in their 40s in their 50s
who had a lot of life experience and it
was just so understanding about how you
know when you grow up like your
responsibilities change life changes I
mean honestly I think I'm going to print
out some of those comments and just
frame them around the office because
anytime I feel down or I feel
unmotivated or I'm like why am I even
doing all of this it would just be so
cool to read words from the community
now the main topic of this video is
going to be animation and I'm going to
talk about that later in this video but
as this is like a weekly or so Dev vog I
do want to touch on the other things
that I've been working on since
animation is a feature that I haven't
personally been working on and it's also
been around for a while it's kind of
like me catching up on on things and I
think that honest ly I've got so much
content in terms of devad vogs for this
year because there are so many features
I haven't talked about and there's so
much work that's happened behind the
scenes that I haven't talked about so
I'm psyched about that I hope you are as
well me personally what I've started
trying to do is weekly live streams
where I work on Hazel on big Hazel
proper Hazel there are still some things
wrapping up that are somewhat preventing
me from doing that consistently but I'm
really excited to very soon hopefully
start doing that consistently every
Monday night Australian time I'm going
to try and do a big Hazel live stream
just a just a Dev stream really where I
just work on the engine no pressure to
make content specifically it's just
going to be me programming chatting to
you guys in chat that kind of thing and
so last time I did that last Monday was
I worked on thumbnails in big hael
because this was a feature that I well I
started I have this thing right where
I'll get really excited to do a feature
in Hazel and the thing is Hazel is an
engine there are literally like this is
one of the things that I really love
about game engines the fact that almost
any Tech that you're interested in
either learning about or creating you
can probably somehow fit it into a game
engine so for example oh I'm interested
in path tracing and offline rendering
yeah that that belongs in a game engine
turns out as well these days AI you want
to learn about how to maybe make a
neural network or do some kind of AI
behaviors well that's perfect for a game
engine because then you can properly
visualize it and maybe make some
interactive experience out of it uh I
don't know maybe you're interested in
like geography and you want to like
create maps of the world well yeah you
know terrain system system for a game
engine like massive Maps you probably
see my point like you could honestly
just anything you're interested in like
the crazy audio stuff Jay is doing as
well with like R tracing and whatever
like that stuff yeah exploring that Tech
also really fits well into a game engine
so it's almost like this kind of just
massive tool of just every Tech piece of
technology you can really think of and
that's one of the reasons why I like
game engines and I like working on them
but anyway back to the original point I
have this tendency to one day wake up
and be like I want to do this I want to
explore this and instead of me you know
starting maybe a new project which is
what I would have done in the past for
some of the things I can just open up
Hazel and be like I'm just going to do
it straight inside Hazel and the really
cool thing about developing this code
base you know because I've been working
on Hazel for I think 6 years now there's
so much like API and tooling and stuff
built into it that it's so much easier
to just use Hazel almost as a framework
not really because I'm still building it
into like the front face faing user
interface and I'm I'm integrating it as
a proper engine feature usually however
the process of working on technology or
you know software we'll say inside Hazel
is obviously very different than say raw
C++ it's almost like hazel is becoming a
little bit of a language and this
happens with any large piece of
technology you know going into Unreal
Engine for example and doing a would be
very very different than going into C++
and just doing a because it's almost
like I mean they have their own meta
language Hazel isn't isn't that advanced
but still having this this Library this
backing this API and everything makes
things very different and so I'll wake
up one day and I'll be like I want to
implement this feature in Hazel and then
I'll spend a few days on it and then
I'll be like H actually I really need to
get that video done on time so I'll just
start working on the the the real work
we'll say that has a deadline and then
I'll forget about the feature and never
return to it and so I have about I swear
20 30 just branches of Hazel not even
branches cuz I haven't committed any
code it's all local just like copies of
Hazel with like a one feature partially
completed some of it's like you know 10%
completed some of it's 90% completed and
one of those features was thumbnails
about a year year and a half maybe ago I
was like yeah you know the content
browser and Hazel just has icons it's
got no thumbnails and so that is
obviously a shame because when you're
trying to preview a texture or a model
or a material like there's no way to do
that at the moment so I sat down I
started working on that and that feature
was somewhat forgotten about for a year
and a half and because we started
working on content browser thumbnails
for hazel 2D for the game engine series
I decided to revive the ones in Hazel 3D
to kind of see you know what they were
like how I did that it's a bit of a
different ball game because in 2D really
only what you have is I guess textures
images that kind of thing whereas 3D
you've got materials meshes environment
Maps you have to in order to render say
a 3D mesh into a thumbnail you have to
like set up a scene inside Hazel with
potentially an environment light or some
kind of lighting a camera that's
positioned just in the right place so
that you can generate a an image
basically render an image of that mesh
as it would appear in Hazel and then
save that out to some kind of maybe cach
into a file or just save it in memory as
a as an image that you can then render
onto that thumbnail in the content
browser so it's a bit of a process now
if you want to see parts of this process
one thing I'm toying with the idea of is
editing some of these live streams down
and maybe including that you know the
highlights maybe or the fun bits of that
process or the informative bits I don't
know as part of like a little bit of a
cut that would go inside these Dev logs
so let me know what you think of that
idea but yeah Monday nights twitch.tv/
The Cho that's where these streams
typically happen I'm going to try and do
that as much as I can this year and I
think now we should talk about the very
very big complex feature that is
animation in Hazel sometimes it's really
hard when there's a lot to show because
I want to show you guys everything but
the fact of the matter is a lot of these
things that we work on they are rather
complicated they have a lot of features
a lot of things you can do with them I
mean it's a game engine there's
obviously a lot you can do but I want to
keep things interesting for people so
what I'm about to show you is the latest
edition of Hazel's animation system
skeletal animation system this is
something that zerox or gym has worked
on for a very long time years I think at
this point and it's obviously a very
important system to have for a game
engine so what I want to do today is
show you a little scene that we made
which uses this animation system for
this main character over here now I
would love to show you how to do all of
this character animation in Hazel from
scratch but I worry that that would
primarily be useful for people actually
using Hazel I don't know maybe it would
be nice for you guys to just see the
workflow and see what it's like and see
the system that we've built let me know
in the comments below if that's
something something you're interested in
seeing but what I'll do today is we're
just going to take a look at this scene
and I'm going to kind of show you how it
was put together maybe I'll edit it a
little bit I don't really have a plan
for this to be honest we're just going
to see what happens so let me play the
scene first so I can show you what this
is so w ASD as you would expect uh
controls this character over here we can
walk around we can jump with space and
the biggest uh difference I guess with
this scene compared to the animation
system that we had say last time I
showed you animation and Hazel is the
fact that well visually what we can see
here is just that these animations now
blend together so you can see that if I
transition from say walking to stopping
or I jump and then I land and you know I
can combine any you know I can run with
shift and then I can jump and then I can
kind of turn around and everything's
just really really smooth everything's
like butter there's no like snapping of
animations together so visually that's
the biggest difference but the other
huge new change is the way that this
scene is actually put together or
specifically the way that these
animations are put together before we
take a look at how they're put together
as well I just want to mention that
obviously this has a physics collider uh
in fact I think if we hit contrl P I
might have to actually change a setting
over here okay here we go so this shows
the actual physics collider so you can
see it's like a captal collider and
that's what encompasses this character
that's why we're on the ground we're not
falling through the ground we can bump
into things we can also like climb this
car for example if we struggle a little
bit so all of that all of this is hooked
in with the physics system and the other
important thing to note I would say is
root motion so if you actually watch the
feet of the character you can see they
align perfectly with the amount of
distance the character travels and
that's because the amount of distance
the character travels is actually tied
in with the animation system so it's not
just us moving a captal forward and then
an animation playing it's actually
subject to that animation so it's like I
don't know there's lots of names for it
Locomotion root motion it's just the
idea that we have almost animation
driven gameplay as opposed to just
here's an animation playing and here's
the actual character moving and
interacting with the world which is
important obviously you want to make
some things animation driven and some
things should not be animation driven so
it's good that we have this option okay
anyway enough of like playing around
with this scene let me show you how it
was made and specifically I guess how
the animation falls into this so we have
this character here and again I won't
show you how to set this up from scratch
if you are interested in seeing that let
me know in the comments below and I'll
make that in a future devlog but over
here we have an animation component this
is just something that you can add
through this if you import this mesh and
you want to import the animations that
come with it for example you can also
set up an entity that way so you don't
necessarily have to manually add all
these components obviously but we have
this animation component and inside here
we have an animation graph so this is an
actual asset if I just search for say
character then you'll see that we have
an animation graph here it is over here
so if I double click on this or this
doesn't matter uh we have this animation
graph view I'll dock it over here and
hopefully my face cam won't get too much
in the way so this animation graph is
definitely quite cool and I could I
could spend well over an hour talking
about this stuff so again I will try and
keep this brief a quick note you might
notice that that this UI is similar to I
don't know if we have any Audi graphs
here but I'll try and put it up in post
the audiograph system that we had the JM
made that's because this is the same so
it's cool that we're able to reuse you
know UI components and this whole kind
of graph node compiler system for more
than just audio we're now using it for
animation I've got some plans to use it
in the future possibly in the distant
future for things like render passes and
custom rendering all of that stuff maybe
one day we'll use it for like a a
material system like a Shader system but
anyway I just wanted to give a shout out
to Jay because his system is obviously
very very useful to have so over here we
have a saate machine if I just show you
roughly how this is made if we hit edit
on the state machine so we have like
these different animation States these
two two over here are basically called
quick States and then this one is kind
of a full state which has inside it if
we double click another animation graph
which takes in an input as you can see
and goes into a blend space which you
can hit edit and control over here so
it's a decently complicated and thus
flexible system which is pretty cool the
the breadcrumbs are up here so you can
go back to wherever you need to go to
and then we have these transitions
between states so you can see for
example that character Idol will go to
and from movement depend depending on a
particular characteristic which is this
movement speed in this case being
greater than zero if it's greater than
zero it will transition from character
Idol to movement because we need to
start moving and vice versa it will
transition back to character idle if the
movement speed is less than or equal to
zero there's also this transition
duration it just means that we can
control how long it takes to transition
between say two different animations and
this can obviously be hooked up into
whatever other node we want but as an
example if I go to the movement one
here's the transition to movement two
character character falling uh actually
I think this one would be better to
change so for example this transition
between being idle which is where we
currently are and falling which is that
like I'm in the air animation I can set
the duration to something a bit longer
say 1 second let's do 1 second there and
back I'll compile and save this so now
if I play this you can see that if I
jump and then go back down the
transition well it takes a second now
and it's very very smooth which is cool
because everything is being interpolated
obviously but that's just an idea I
definitely want that to be more Snappy
so let me just adjust that to 01 and as
I mentioned of course it can be
dependent on whatever you want it to be
dependent on okay so to show you a
little bit more about how this graph
system works and how this animation
system in general Works instead of us
using a state machine let me create
something else specifically I'm want to
create an animation player which is
generally what you get by default if you
just import an animation and this is
very simple to understand this just has
an output pose which I'll now connect to
the actual output that we see here and
it has an animation asset to play so if
I drop this down you can see we we have
for example this character Running
Animation let me select that I will
compile and save this and now you can
see that this is running so this is now
very simple to understand hopefully it's
just this animation it's playing there's
no logic really to it is just playing
that animation the playback speed as I
mentioned is something that you can of
course control I mean I was talking
about the transition speed but that's
similar here and to give a little bit of
a deeper example what we can do is we
can add an input say if we wanted the
playback speed to be controlled from
elsewhere I'll call this input let's
just call it like playback speed let me
make this a little bit wider it's going
to be a float uh default value sure zero
and then I'll drag this into here and
now you can see we have an input that we
can take in I'll compile and save this
it's going to be zero because that's a
default value but where is this inut
coming from you'll see now inside the
character entity and inside the
animation component that we now have a
playback speed variable over here that's
a float and I I can set this to whatever
and that obviously means I don't have to
recompile this graph I can you know set
this to really whatever I want and this
being a normal field like this means
that we can also set it from C pretty
easily so if you have scripting Behavior
you want to tie into this that's also
quite easy to do now there are also you
know things here like events so these
are specific events that you can trigger
when something happens so every time
this animation Loops or it finishes you
may want to trigger an event and this
ties into what I was talking about how
you can drive things with animation so
you can actually drive your gameplay
with animation rather than you know
having to time things I mean no one
really does that but I feel like some
people who might not know how this works
they might imagine that animation plays
and then you just need to manually like
time things together I don't know if
people actually think that I'm pretty
sure I did back in the day so maybe this
is helpful to someone just saying that
you can tie in animation events or
events inside animation I could even
create a key frame inside my animation
and blend Ender which triggers something
here if I wanted it to be like say at
frame 40 out of 100 frame animation I
wanted an event to happen in my C and
get triggered I could set all of that up
which is really cool talking about the
stuff really makes me uh want to
actually use it in a game I'm pretty
sure I'm going to do the l d game Jam
coming up in about mid April so I will
definitely have the chance to sit down
and use some of these systems there's so
much to explore here I mean if we wanted
to we could just go to math and be like
I want to multiply
this like multiply float I want to
multiply this by some special number
such as I don't know the movement speed
for example and then I want to put that
into the playback speed so if I now hit
play and then I move you can see it's
going to first of all move a lot slower
because as I mentioned the movement the
actual character moving the entity
moving is dependent on the animation
that's why you're seeing this but also
you can see I can I can also run and the
animation speed actually plays a lot
slower as well because it's dependent on
movement as an example let me change the
walk speed to like 15 and so now you can
see I'm walking super fast and the
animation is also playing super fast now
if I hit space to jump you can see it's
obviously it's never transitioning
between animations this is entirely the
Run animation it almost looked like
there was two different animations
between walking this is now me holding
shift for sprinting but the Sprint speed
is slower than walk speed so looks like
I'm walking but this almost look like
two different animations but it was all
just entirely this character Running
Animation because I'm not using the
state machine anymore but I guess the
difference is that it's controlling the
playback speed now based on the movement
speed multiplying the two together
that's why jumping is not going to
obviously transition to anything cuz I
don't have that state machine but I'm
able to use these inputs together to
create this and the entities moving at
the right pace so you can see the
footsteps like line up obviously with
the ground and everything is really cool
so yeah look hatsoft to 0x really cool
system this is all custom by the way I
don't think he's using any libraries he
might be using some auxiliary libraries
but all of this animation system is
entirely custom written in Hazel so yeah
definitely really grateful to him I'm
actually super excited to use animation
together with some other technology that
I will reveal soon any I hope you guys
enjoy this devlog let me know what you
thought as I mentioned the these devlogs
really they're as in development as
Hazel is so if you have suggestions
please tell me what you like please tell
me what you didn't like in this video
please help me understand how I can
better communicate this process of
developing a game engine with all of you
thanks for watching as always and I'll
see you next week with another dead Vlog
goodbye